infinity war may feel like the climax to
the Marvel film universe but it's only
going to mark a new beginning there are
a slew of Marvel flicks scheduled to hit
cinemas over the next few years as
franchises continue to grow and expand
their rosters it's getting harder to
keep track of everything that's
happening here's every movie Marvel has
planned after infinity war both within
the MCU and across other franchises
ant-man and the wasp Marvel released the
first ant-man in the wasp trailer a
little earlier than expected dropping it
the day after the Black Panther premiere
director Peyton Reed announced that the
film had wrapped in November 2017
but because it comes out after infinity
war fans assumed the details would be
scarce until after Thanos shows up on
earth judging from the trailer however
it appears that ant-man and the wasp
will take place before the events of
infinity war the trailer opens with hero
Scott Lang discussing the aftermath of
civil war with partner and
crime-stopping hope Van Dyne and there's
no sign that Earth's been shattered by
Thanos in his black order instead the
plot looks like it will center around
Lang going on the run with Hank Pym
who's shrinking technology is now in
high demand by all manner of shady types
the trailer also gives us our first
glimpse at Laurence Fishburne as Doctor
Bill Foster a scientist who became known
as black Goliath in Marvel Comics after
messing with the Pym particle and
gaining powers
there is no sign of michelle pfeiffer
however who will be appearing as hank
PIMs wife Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige told fans that Pfeiffer was their
dream choice in the role of Janet Van
Dyne the first owner of the wasp suit
Captain Marvel
we've known for some time now that brie
Larson will be Captain Marvel but what
we've all been dying to find out is
whether or not she'll be showing up in
infinity war turns out she definitely
won't be co-director Joe Russo put him
into the rumor while speaking to
comicbook.com
of course the fact that Russo
specifically denied her involvement in
the third Avengers flick seems to
indicate that she will indeed appear in
Avengers 4 which will hit screens after
Captain Marvel in 2019 as far as the
rest of the casting is concerned Jude
Law and Vin Mendelsohn have both agreed
to terms and will be appearing as Marvel
and Yan raagh according to movie Webb
Lee pace has also signed on to reprise
his role as Ronan the accuser
despite having exploded in guardians of
the galaxy Captain Marvel enthusiasts
still shouldn't expect a rigidly
faithful adaptation of the source
material
untitled Avengers infinity Wars sequel
Marvel originally wanted to shoot
Avengers three and four together though
in the end of that approach proved too
big and asked for the studio given the
sheer size of the ensemble cast many of
whom are in high demand elsewhere Chris
Pratt for example has had to juggle
Marvel duties with the Jurassic world
sequel the problem looks like it might
get worse going forward as the Russos
have revealed that they're considering
as many as 67 named characters for
inclusion in infinity war even Pepper
Potts is rumored to be suiting up for
the big showdown with fan OHS ru when
the Avengers the next Avengers am I
allowed to say I say you are okay the
title of the sequel is being kept under
wraps at Marvel because it's a spoiler
for infinity war Joe Russo explained it
is certainly part of the concept of the
title is that it's advancing the
narrative we're gonna sit on that until
we feel the time is right and when
people have absorbed the first movie
enough untitled spider-man homecoming
sequel after Marvel and Sony finally
came to a mutually beneficial
arrangement regarding the use of
spider-man it seemed unlikely that the
wall-crawler would give just a single
solo movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Tom Holland made his debut as
Peter Parker in 2016 s Captain America's
Civil War before fronting his own
standalone movie last summer and he
confirmed that a sequel was in the
pipeline same we've just finished
spider-man homecoming and we're talking
about the second one and who the villain
is going to be and where we're going
according to recent reports Parker will
be facing off against a female enemy
this time out Marvel is apparently on
the hunt for a European actress in her
20s to play a femme fatale type and
emerging details on principal
photography are leading many to assume
that some of the movie will be set in
Europe with a tentative release date of
July 2019 guardians of the galaxy vol 3
if guardians of the galaxy vol 3 was
ever in doubt at marvel studios the box
office numbers posted by the second film
have made certain that the team will be
back for a third round but star-lord
might not be taking center stage this
time out James Gunn told USA Today that
he's already begun working on the
screenplay for the third film which will
apparently involve less Chris Pratt and
more Zoe Saldana the director said he's
talked with the actress about having
Gamora take a more prominent role in the
final Guardians outing casting news is
already starting to trickle through with
Gunn confirming that Elizabeth debicki
will reprise her role as
ayesha the Golden High Priestess of the
sovereign there's nothing official in
terms of release date yet
although Gunn has hinted that will be
seen volume 3 sometime in 2020 ant-man
three Marvel Studios is clearly
expecting the upcoming ant-man sequel to
go down well a third installment in the
Paul Rudd led franchise is already in
the pipeline according to co-star
Michael Pena speaking to IGN about his
film 12 strong pain you let slip that
ant-man three is happening although he
wasn't sure if he'd be needed for it
saying it's a whole different kind of
club to be in the Marvel Universe I
don't know if they'll use me for the
third movie I still really don't know
it's cool to make a little bit of a mark
on that Marvel Universe and it's kind of
a cool club they run a really cool
studio Black Widow
Scarlett Johansson made her debut as
former KGB spy Natasha Romanoff aka
Black Widow in 2010's Iron Man 2 I want
one no eight years later were still
waiting for official confirmation of her
solo movie Kevin Feige first hinted at a
black widow standalone feature in 2014
when he said that her part in the MCU
was very big and that the notion of
exploring that even further in her own
film would be great he reiterated that
Marvel was committed to making the film
happen in 2016 saying I would say
certainly the one creatively and
emotionally that we are most committing
to doing his Black Widow another two
years went without much news though a
recent variety exclusive claims that the
wheels are finally in motion on Black
Widow and that Marvel has hired Jack
Schaeffer to pin the script Johansson
was consulted over the decision to
enlist Schaffer though varieties sources
say the movie is still in early
development and doesn't have any plot
details so far we do have one suggestion
the only thing missing in Black Widows
life
such a klutz what's love old troll dr.
doom
the Fantastic Four don't have a
particularly great track record in
movies but a surprise announcement at
San Diego comic-con 2017 gave some new
hope to fans Noah Hawley the creator of
the FX series Legion wrapped up his
show's panel by revealing that he was
working with Fox to develop a movie for
the Fantastic Four's most iconic villain
teasing it with two words first one is
dr. and the second one is doom
since then Fox has been bought out by
Disney leaving question marks over some
properties in the early stages of
development poly insists that the movie
is still happening although even he's
not sure when telling Collider on some
level were still looking at a period of
time probably a year at the least for
this whole thing to go through I've been
waiting for the phone to ring to see if
anyone is gonna have an opinion silver
and black there's a lot of focus on Tom
Hardy's venom at the moment but Sony has
also set the wheels in motion on silver
and black another upcoming feature based
on the studio spider-man portfolio
silver sable has been both an ally and
an enemy to spider-man over the years
but has never been portrayed on the big
screen before black cat on the other
hand did pop up in the amazing
spider-man 2 well kind of rogue 1 star
Felicity Jones briefly appeared as a
character called Felicia Hardy Black
Cats real name in the comics according
to The Hollywood Reporter Chris Yost who
worked on thor ragnarok has been hired
to tidy up a script penned by lisa joy
the co-creator of HBO's critically
acclaimed Westworld Gina Prince both
wood is slated to direct although the
latest rumors suggest the film was
recently put on indefinite hold some
things never change
laura daphne keen definitely impressed
his Wolverines offspring Laura and Logan
and director James Mangold revealed that
the success of Wonder Woman has brought
a solo outing for the character closer
to reality
he said the film only solidifies more
for studios that there's less to fear
with a female protagonist the more that
keeps getting hit home that ends up
giving me more space turning around and
going well here we are with a female
protagonist that's incredible and what
are we going to do with her and that's
where we are with that right now
dreaming x-men Dark Phoenix this direct
follow-up to 2016 x-men apocalypse will
bring back all the big hitters from the
previous movie with the addition of
Jessica Chastain as one of the film's
villains Dark Phoenix will mark the
directorial debut of Simon Kinberg
although Kinberg has been working on the
x-men films as a writer and producer
since 2006 as the last stand a botched
attempt at adapting the classic Dark
Phoenix saga Kinberg confirmed that the
film will follow the franchise's decade
skipping trend jumping forward from the
80s set apocalypse to a 90s setting it's
scheduled to open November 2018 multiple
man after directing Dark Phoenix Simon
Kinberg will return to the producers
chair to oversee yet another spin-off in
Fox's x-men franchise according to The
Hollywood Reporter Kinberg is in
negotiations with James Franco over the
lead role in a planned adaptation of
multiple man a mutant with the power to
create and control clones of himself
right while casual viewers probably
won't recall the name James mad rocks
the character has actually popped up in
Fox's x-men movies before he was
portrayed by Eric Dane in 2006 as x-men
The Last Stand appearing as one of the
mutants recruited by magneto gambit in
development since 2014
gambit seemed like a sure thing when an
x-men producer confirmed the channing
tatum would play the card tossing mutant
after several directors left the film
Gore Verbinski jumped into the hot seat
and was eyeing a Valentine's Day 2019
release although The Hollywood Reporter
later confirmed that Verbinski has
become the third director to walk
leaving the seemingly cursed project in
limbo once more
Fox has reacted by pushing the release
date to summer 2019 giving itself some
breathing room just in case they can't
find a replacement Tatum remains
attached along with Lizzy Caplan who has
been cast as the film's female lead
hopefully Tatum keeps gambits Cajun
accent
go to easel Venom Sony had been
discussing a venom movie for over a
decade when the studio finally confirmed
that the symbiote solo adventure was
going ahead Tom Hardy is playing Eddie
Brock the first character to take on the
venom moniker in Marvel Comics despite
being a fan favorite the antihero has
only been portrayed in film once when
Topher Grace donned the black for
spider-man 3 oh yeah I know all about
YOU who party is set to play a central
role in what's being dubbed the Sony
Marvel Universe and director Ruben
Fleischer revealed that the film would
follow the Planet of the symbiotes and
lethal protect her comic arts venema
slated for an October 2017 release
spider-man into the spider-verse
African Latino spider-man Miles Morales
was only supposed to be around for four
years in the pages of Marvel's comics as
part of the Ultimate Marvel imprint but
this version of Spidey proved so popular
that Marvel decided to merge him into
the main line and now he'll be the focus
of a feature-length animated movie at
present the film is scheduled to be
released on December 21st 2018 New
Mutants marvel fans everywhere got a
thrill from the trailer for New Mutants
the horror inspired x-men spin-off is
being held by young filmmaker Josh Boone
who took it upon himself personally to
convince Fox it was a property worth
adapting he and co-writer Nate Walt me
put together their own new mutants comic
book based on stories they wanted to
adapt the Fox and the studio loved it
Boone explained it walked them through a
trilogy of new mutant films that would
build on each other it took all the
images we had loved from the series and
strung them together to show them the
movie we wanted to do even then it took
a long time for the film to happen when
we spend a couple of years writing the
script before I went and shot the movie
we worked on it for two or three years I
think shooting has already wrapped on
the film and fans can expect to see it
in theaters in August 2009 teen Deadpool
- after 2016 s Deadpool unexpectedly
became the highest-grossing film in the
x-men franchise keeping the creative
team together for the follow-up seemed
essential that wasn't to be the case
director Tim Miller soon departed the
project and David Leitch of John wick
Fame has since stepped up to direct Josh
Brolin will also be welcomed into the
fold as the time traveler cable Fox
dedicated an entire trailer to
introducing the character in
sizing his war-torn past the trailers
also confirmed that brianna hildebrand
would be returning as negasonic teenage
warhead and that TJ miller would reprise
his role as weasel along with whole new
cast of mutants Deadpool 2 arrives on
May 18th x-force another project
promised by Fox's exports a black ops
team of Marvel mutants far more brutal
than the x-men the film will revolve
around Deadpool and cable x-force you're
absolutely right a report picked up by
movie web states that x-force will begin
filming in October 2018 with Drew
Goddard attached to direct
according to a recent discussing film
exclusive the greenlight remains firmly
on for Goddard's x-force regardless of
the Disney takeover thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]